House of the Dragon episode 5 has a
royal wedding so naturally there's
politics drama and a murder what happens
and what does it mean this video has no
spoilers for hot day beyond episode 5.
the opening sequence is a symbolic
family tree showing the bloodline of
House Targaryen and it's slightly
changed across episodes the symbol for
Alison Hightower now has a bloodline
connecting to her husband King viserys
and there are two Bloodlines coming from
her representing her son aegon and her
daughter Helena the symbol for rhaenyra
now connects to Lenor valarion who she
marries in this episode in the previous
episode viserys told Daemon to go back
to his wife in The Veil so now in the
veil we finally meet daemon's estranged
wife Reya Royce house Royce is famous
for their ancient bronze armor engraved
with Runes of the first men so Reyes
clothes are decorated with runes which
the show's creators copied from
Wikipedia The Royce bronze armor and
their history as bronze Kings is why
Daemon calls Raya his bronze [ __ ] in
Game of Thrones house Royce is led by
bronze John Royce he's the father of
Weimar Royce who gets killed by white
walkers in episode 1. The Royce Castle
is runestone just up the coast from
King's Landing so Daemon arrives and
finds Reya and Raya is immediately
suspicious of him glancing over her
shoulder she insults Daemon saying that
he should have sex with a sheep because
previously Daemon said that in The Veil
The Sheep are prettier than the women
Raya mocks Daemon saying that viserys
rejected Daemon by making rhaenyra heir
to the throne instead of him and Reya
says that her marriage to Daemon is
still unconsummated they've never had
sex Rhea says that Daemon couldn't
finish and we know know that Daemon has
a history of sexual dysfunction of not
being able to have sex with mazaria and
rhaenyra so Reya really knows how to
hurt daemon's insecurities about sex and
family she's just as sharp tongued as he
is so it's easy to see how Rhea and
daemon's personalities clashed and their
marriage failed Daemon comes close Rhea
grabs her bow her horse rears up Daemon
touches it and it falls so that Reya is
crushed paralyzing her then Daemon kills
Reya with a rock to make it look like
she died by accident falling off her
horse the books say that Reya died in a
tragic mishap falling and cracking her
head on a rock Daemon was on the
stepstones at the time so in the books
reya's death May really have been an
accident in the show it is ambiguous
where the Daemon came here planning to
kill Reya or if he just took the
opportunity but his hated wife is is
dead which means that Daemon is now free
to remarry whether For Love or for lust
or for power
Otto Hightower leaves King's Landing
viserys fired Otto as hand of the king
because Otto had manipulated viserys and
undermined rhaenyra to try and make
Otto's grandson aegon heir to the throne
Otto blames his daughter Alison for
getting him fired because Alison sided
with rhaenyra and said rhaenyra was
innocent of having sex with Damon But
Otto says that Alison shouldn't support
rhaenyra because if Rainier takes the
throne after viserys dies they'll be War
many laws won't accept a female ruler
and would prefer Alison's son aegon on
the throne
Otto says rhaenyra will need to kill
Alison's children because they're a
threat to her claim
Otto says they must get aegon on the
throne or else rhaenyra will destroy
them they must win the Game of Thrones
or die
Otto loves Allison and wants to protect
her but Allison's only in this dangerous
situation because Otto pushed Alison to
marry viserys and pushed for aegon to be
air Alison went along with her family's
Ambitions and now she and her children
are in danger Larice strong the clubfoot
is the son of Lionel strong and the
brother of Harwin strong Laris tells
Alison subtly and indirectly that
maester Melos gave rhaenyra Moon tea
hinting that rhaenyra lied to Alison and
that she really did have sex Lara says
Alison can't rely on rhaenyra and that
Laris will be Alison's Ally Solaris
creates conflict here turning Alison
against rhaenyra and positions himself
as a friend to the queen it's similar to
how Littlefinger in Game of Thrones
creates chaos to gain power but how does
Laris know about rhaenyra's Moon tea
Lara says that he's just observant we
saw him listening to the ladies at the
hunt maybe he also has spies like
mazarias little birds maybe he knows the
C secrets of the red keep like Daemon
maybe he's working with the maesters
Larissa's dad Lionel did study at the
Citadel or maybe laras's knowledge is
magical YouTuber Joe magician argues
that larus might be a green Seer
greenseers are people like bran and
bloodraven who use the magic of the old
gods and the weirwood trees greenseers
can see through the eyes of weirwoods
and see through the eyes of animals can
see through time and space greenseers
have the blood of the first men the
original humans in Westeros that
includes how Stark like bran and house
Blackwood like bloodraven and house
strong like Laris he also descends from
the first men bloodraven says that
greenseers have powerful minds but are
physically weak just like Laris is weak
with his clubfoot so it is plausible
that Laris could be a green Seer how
strong is based at harrenhal and
parenthal just happens to be right next
door to the Isle of faces a mysterious
island sacred to the old gods The Isle
has a Grove of weirwood trees watched
over by the mystical green men maybe the
Curious Larice strong visited the Isle
of faces and learned Magic from the
green men maybe he can skin change into
animals in the books bloodraven was once
a spymaster whose skin changed into
crows to spy on people in the books Arya
Stark also has this power and she skin
changes into a cat to spy on people so
maybe Laris skin changes into these rats
we've seen in Hot D using them to spy
and listen in on conversations in the
red cape and he could see through this
weirwood to witness all the important
conversations that happen here this
scene with Alison visually connects
Laris with the weirwood at first it
seems almost like larice's voice is
coming from the tree like he's watching
through its eyes for more on this Theory
check out Joe magician so far we don't
know for sure how larus knows what he
knows but he clearly is a mysterious and
powerful character and in a way he says
he's similar to Alison because Laris
talks about a flower from braavos that
isn't native to King's Landing but still
thrives here just like laryus and
Allison aren't native to the red keep
they aren't Royal targaryens but they
may still Thrive and grow strong here in
the background there's an image of a
lemon tree which might be a subtle hint
to a mystery in the books in the books
Daenerys remembers that she once lived
in a house in braavos with a lemon tree
outside which is weird because the books
also say that lemon trees don't grow in
braavos they only grow in warmer
climates to the South it's not native
like larice's flower some fans speculate
that daenerys's house with the lemon
tree was actually in Dawn or someplace
for a conspiracy
viserys and rhaenyra sail to driftmark
the island of house valerion viserys
gets seasick and pukes so his new hand
of the king Lionel strong gives him a
cloth to wipe the vomit in Game of
Thrones Jaime says the king shits and
the Hand wipes it's the job of the hand
of the king to solve the king's problems
and to clean up his mess it's
interesting that viserys takes this
miserable boat Journey instead of just
flying a dragon viserys doesn't have his
own dragon anymore but he could have
hitched a ride on rhaenyra's Dragon
Cyrax we've seen dragons used as
passenger vehicles before like there are
big scaly flying minibus but maybe
viserys is afraid to ride dragons he
said that dragons are an uncontrollable
Dangerous Power they arrive at the
valerion castle called High Tide the
valerians originally lived in a smaller
Castle but after Corliss made heaps of
money on his voyages he built this new
you a better Castle high tide is on its
own small tidal Island which is only
accessible by foot When the tide is low
which shows the valerion connection to
Sea power and ships Lionel is offended
that the valerions don't greet King
viserys outside it's meant to be a big
deal when the king visits your home like
when King Robert visits the Starks in
Game of Thrones but viserys is just
greeted by Elena valarion the daughter
of cordless and rhaenys previously
viserys rejected Lena's marriage
proposal so now sending Lena to meet
viserys is a reminder of how insulted
Corliss felt that his family was denied
a royal marriage Corliss meets viserys
inside Seated on his Driftwood Throne
according to ancient legend this Throne
was given to the valerions by the Merlin
King a kind of mermaid sea God it is a
total power move that Corliss has the
king come to him and that call stands
over viserys Corliss is a very proud man
who wants everyone to know how great he
is this room is called the Hall of nine
it's full of treasures and trophies that
call us got on his famous 9C voyages
there's a snake or aery and a hanging
City and a giant seashell and now
Corliss adds the crab feeder's mask to
his collection colas has achieved so
much that he lives in a museum of his
own awesomeness and yet Corliss is still
not satisfied viserys proposes for his
daughter and heir rainierer to marry
corliss's son and Heir Lenor he says
this will finally unite the targaryens
and valerions which is funny because
Corliss valerion's wife rhaenys
Targaryen is standing right there
they're already United but Corliss is
still angry that rhaenys didn't inherit
the throne back at the Harren Hall
Council the marriage of rhaenyra and
Lenor is really about making up for that
rejection and finally getting a valerion
into the Royal Line Corliss negotiates
the details like traditionally children
have their father's family name so will
Rainier and Leno's children the next
rulers of Westeros be called valerion
viserys doesn't want the Targaryen Royal
name to end with this marriage so he
says that rhaenyra and Leno's children
will be called valerion but when one
inherits the throne they will be called
Targaryen to continue the Targaryen
Dynasty so both viserys and Corliss are
very concerned with their legacy and
pride viserys may also be thinking a
vagon the conqueror's dream that a
Targaryen will defeat the white walkers
but they agree to the marriage forging a
stronger alliance between the two last
Valyrian Dragon riding families
meanwhile rhaenyra and Lenor make their
own agreement Lane is gay Joffrey
lawnmuth is his boyfriend so marrying
rhaenyra is not what either of them want
Corliss says that lane all will grow out
of being gay but rhaenyra accepts Leno's
sexuality she uses an analogy that some
people like dark and some people like
Goose this is based on a line in the
books where Melos says that it doesn't
matter that Lena is gay he should marry
rhaenyra anyway because Milos doesn't
like fish but when fish is served he'll
eat it anyway rhaenyra and Leno agree
that they'll do their Duty get married
make some babies but on the side they'll
hook up with who they want lane or can
stay with Joffrey and rhaenyra can have
Kristen or whoever else she wants
rhaenyra must have been inspired earlier
when Daemon told her that you can have
sex outside of marriage rhaenyra and
Leno are both happy with his compromise
but polyamorous relationships can cause
drama if combined with secrecy and
politics and Dragons r Rainey says that
this marriage puts her son Lenor in
danger like Otto she says there'll be
conflict between rhaenyra and aegon for
the throne Corliss says he's willing to
fight to put a valerion's child on the
throne he says it's Justice to make up
for rhaenys not getting the Throne of
the harrenhal council but rainy says
she's over that she cares more about her
family's safety than she cares about The
Throne she suggests that callus is
really motivated not by Justice but by
pride and power but despite her fears
rhaenys is dragged along with corliss's
ambitions like Emma was with viserys and
Allison was with Otto Kristen Cole feels
guilty and ashamed that he broke his
King's Guard Oath by having sex with
rhaenyra so Kristen asks rhaenyra to run
away with him to the east to escape
their responsibilities as a kingsguard
and princess and to be free and married
together rhaenyra has said before that
she wants to escape her responsibilities
and wants to travel the East but lately
rhaenyra has accepted her political
duties viserys told her about aegon the
conqueror's dream that the targaryens
must protect the world from the white
walkers he made her promise to uphold
this so rhaenyra says she'll stay but
she says she could still keep Kristin as
a lover on the side Kristen is insulted
by this he doesn't want to be her [ __ ]
which seems hypocritical Kristen expects
rhaenyra to give up her crown and her
family and her home but Kristen is too
proud himself to be a Paramore this goes
deep for Chris system because Kristen's
whole identity his greatest achievement
is being a king's God he swore a sacred
oath of Chastity not to have sex and he
can't live in that white cloak knowing
that it's a lie knowing that he could be
killed for his crime he sees running to
the east as a way to escape that shame
and marrying rhaenyra as a way to fix
his sin running East is not a great idea
but it's the only idea Kristen has so
when rhaenyra says no Kristen loses his
one hope for a tolerable life
after speaking with Alaris Allison
suspects that rhaenyra lied and that
maybe she did have sex with Daemon so
Alison questions rhaenyra's guard
Kristen though like Otto Allison is too
proper and ashamed to directly say that
she thinks rhaenyra and Daemon had sex
so Kristen thinks that Alison is talking
about rhaenyra having sex with him
Kristen is so full of Shame and fear so
desperate for repentance that he
confesses and tells Alison that he had
sex with rhaenyra he asks to be put to
death rather than gilded or tortured
because when the kingsguard lucama
strong had sex they cut off his penis
and sent him to the wall and when the
kingsguard Terence toyne has sex the
King has him cut to Pieces slowly
Kristen wants a quick honorable end but
Alison doesn't give him punishment or
Absolution she's so stunned that she
just lets him him go leaving Kristen to
sink deeper into guilt and fear knowing
he could be killed for his crime at any
time Alison is angry not just that
rhaenyra lied to her about not having
sex but also because Alison believing
rhaenyra is part of what got her dad
Otto fired if she can't trust rhaenyra
and if Otto is gone Alison is more alone
than ever King viserys is very sick from
the infection that started in his hand
viserys's actor said that he's now got
something like leprosy deteriorating his
body and his bones it's partly a
metaphor for his stress and his failure
as a king Grand maester Melos treats
viserys with leeches a new maester
called Orwell says a different treatment
might be more effective but Melos
refuses which is suspicious Melos talks
as though his treatments are working but
they're not this sickness started with a
tiny cut and now the Kings falling to
pieces and yet Melos refuses to try
different treatments that might help so
some fans speculate that Melos is
deliberately letting the king die maybe
in conspiracy with Otto and the high
Towers they might hope that if viserys
is weak or dead they could more easily
get aegon onto the throne viserys knows
that he might die soon so he thinks on
his legacy and wonders if he'd be
remembered more if he had fought in
battles and made conquests his model
city of valyria is behind him so the
Empire of his ancestors is on viserys's
mind but Lionel says that it's a good
thing that viserys's Reign was peaceful
he continued the peaceful Legacy of his
grandfather King jeheris viserys knows
that Lionel is right but he still has an
ego and knows that they don't sing songs
for peaceful Kings the Valar come to
King's Landing for the wedding and for
the first time we see rainis Dragon
called melis the Red Queen melis is a
magnificent Scarlet she Dragon first
ridden by Alyssa Targaryen the mother of
viserys and Daemon melis was once the
fastest dragon in Westeros and the other
Dragon here is sea smoke lenor's Dragon
Inside Lord Jason Lannister arrives with
his twin brother Thailand Jason makes a
dumb women joke and rhaenyra is not
impressed the valerians arrive in Rich
clothing showing off their wealth and
then just as viserys is about to speak
Daemon Targaryen saunters in as though
he owns the place just last episode
viserys told Daemon to never return but
now viserys let's Daemon return from
Exile again viserys seems incapable of
saying no to his family and since his
brother and daughter and wife all want
different things this is a recipe for
conflict when viserys starts his speech
he's interrupted Again by Allison in a
brilliant green dress earlier Alison
felt alone and betrayed so now she Rises
defiantly and asserts her own power as
Queen green is a Hightower color Laris
says that the Hightower Beacon burns
green at times of War so this is a
rallying call for the hightowers to
stand by Alison previously Alison wore
red Targaryen clothes so now wearing
green sets her apart from and against
rhaenyra Targaryen previously rhaenyra
called Alison's sister because they were
close like equals but now Alison calls
rhaenyra's step-daughter setting herself
above rhaenyra green is a color of envy
and the director said that Alison had
always been envious of her Rainier is
freedom while Alison felt trapped in her
Duty Alison has always been a proper
lady so she shows her power not with
swords or dragons but with a dress
armoring herself in feminine fashion her
uncle Lord Hobart Hightower tells Alison
That Old Town stands with her so the
battle lines are being drawn if there's
Conflict for the throne between Alison's
son aegon and rhaenyra it looks like the
hightowers will support aegon while the
valerians will support rhaenyra and
lanor and all this tension is evident of
the wedding rhaenyra and Lenor perform a
dance that looks like some Dragon
meeting ritual with flapping wings maybe
this is an ancient Valyrian dance
rhaenyra's actor said they called one of
these dance moves the smelly fart Lenor
says dancing is like combat because in
the books there's a war called the dance
of the Dragons dancing being a metaphor
for of the deadly motion of politics and
violence so as the guests join the
flowing movements of this dance emotions
and Ambitions swirl amongst them Daemon
looks hungrily at rhaenyra Alison glares
in green Kristen boils with jealousy and
shame and there are close-ups of meat
being cut with knives foreshadowing
bloody violence according to interviews
this drummer is mushroom mushroom is the
dwarf Jester who tells Tales of sex and
murder in the book Fire and Blood Gerald
Royce confronts Daemon and accuses him
of murdering Rayo Royce Daemon acts like
he doesn't care and says that since Raya
was the heir to runestone but Reya had
no kids Daemon will claim the lordship
of runestone for himself he says that
he'll talk to the lady of the veil Jane
Aaron about it and Gerald looks shocked
maybe Gerald wants to inherit runestone
himself since he was reya's cousin so
maybe daemon's implication here is that
if Gerald shuts up about Daemon killing
Reya Daemon will let Gerald have
runestone but if Gerald pushes his
accusation and creates problems Daemon
will take runestone just to [ __ ] with
Gerald and it seems to work Gerald backs
off and Daemon escapes punishment for
his murder Daemon flirts with Elena
valarion Daemon seems helplessly
attracted to women with a Valyrian blood
and silver hair maybe because Valyrian
women can birth Valyrian children who
can ride dragons having Dragon Riders as
children could be a way for Daemon to
gain power though last we heard Elena
was to be betrothed to the son of the
Sea Lord of braavos so she might not be
single right now after Lana Daemon
flirts with the next Valyrian blonde his
niece and the bride rhaenyra and
rhaenyra flirts back saying
sarcastically but actually kind of for
real though that Daemon should take her
and marry her rhaenyra is still
attracted to Daemon and has desires that
lanor won't satisfy Leno's boyfriend
Joffrey figures out that Kristen
Israel's secret lover he can tell by how
Kristen watches rhaenyra so Joffrey
tells Kristen that he knows Kristen's
secret he says that together they can
protect both their secret Affairs
Joffrey's affair with Lenor and Kristen
Swift rhaenyra you can read this as a
threat like Kristen better keep Joffrey
and Leno's a fair secret or else Joffrey
will expose Kristen's secret affair but
while Joffrey is fairly relaxed about
these secrets Kristen is a ticking Time
Bomb full of pent-up resentment shame
and suicidal rage full of emotion and
scared that Joffrey will blab his secret
Kristen snaps he starts a fight he
punches Lena as chaos so Lionel sends
his son Harwin in to get the princess to
safety Harwin breakbones is said to be
the strongest Knight in Westeros so if
you need muscle he's your guy in the
fight Kristen's emotions pour out as he
beats Joffrey to death
when we first met Kristen he seemed like
a fairy tale Noble White Knight but
beneath that superficial appearance
Kristen is a brutal killer who makes his
feelings and bad decisions everyone
else's problem the show's creators
describe Kristen as a thug and his
violence was only made worse by his
Knighthood Knights are expected to
defend their honor with violence a
kingsguard knight is taught that sex is
wrong but killing is fine the books
often explore how Knighthood and honor
culture Empower bad men to hurt innocent
people in the books Kristen kills
Joffrey not at a wedding but at a
tournament while fighting in a melee
which is a much less terrible crime
deaths do happen at tournaments like
those nights in episode 1 but beating a
man to death at a royal wedding and
punching the Future King consort in the
face of various serious crimes so it's
surprising that Kristen somehow escapes
the wedding with his weapons and goes to
the godswood Kristen can't imagine any
honorable life for himself so he
prepares to commit suicide but Kristen
is stopped by Allison Allison needs
allies Kristen needs purpose and both
these guys are angry at rhaenyra so
maybe they'll make an alliance and queen
Alison might protect Kristen from
punishment for his murder after
Joffrey's death the planned celebrations
are canceled rhaenyra and Leno are
hastily married as Lenor sobs for his
dead lover in the books Joffrey is
comatose for six days and Leno stays by
his side until Joffrey dies King viserys
collapses again and his crown falls off
his head highlighting that viserys may
die soon and that the succession for his
crown is uncertain a rat laps that
Joffrey's blood which could represent
Laris whose words to Alison earlier fed
this conflict the rat could also
represent all the Lords and Knights of
Westeros who were eager to fight for
power like crows feasting on the corpse
of House Targaryen everyone feels that
war is coming and they can almost taste
the blood
if you want to know more about the magic
of the old gods about bran and
bloodraven and Arya skin changing a cat
you gotta check out the Game of Thrones
books the main Series has bran and
arya's Magic a night of the Seven
Kingdoms features bloodravens past life
as a spymaster the world of Ice and Fire
is full of World building and a short
summary of House of the dragon and Fire
and Blood tells the full story of hot
day you can get any one of these on
audiobook for free right now at
audible.com ASX sign up for a Premium
Plus trial membership and you can get an
audiobook to keep even if you cancel the
trial you can get any Game of Thrones
book or the Lord of the Rings or Dune
membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audiobooks and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com ASX or text ASX to
500-500 thanks for watching please like
And subscribe and check out the altshift
X podcasts link below thanks to the
patrons including sacked attack corn
chaitanya Carrie steyer Maxwell Georg
Jerry Cairo Minot Laurie perrick and
Thanos is God cheers